en quelques secondes le plus violent
séisme de ces deux derniers siècles a
rayé Agadir de la
car Agadir est désormais une ville morte
l'ordre d'évacuation en a chassé les
derniers survivants qui n'avaient pas
encore fu ses
ruines et quelle ruine depuis la casba
jusqu'au port où le séisme a laissé sa
marque au milieu des débris des grues et
des installations
desqu on a a donner au Morts une
sépulture particulière en raison de leur
[Applaudissements]
nom il a fallu employer les bulldoers
pour seconder les équipes de fossoyeurs
et creuser une immense fausse
[Musique]
commune dès les premières heures le roi
du Maroc était venu rendre visite au
rescapé auquel on avait ouvert un camp
de toil ils sont des milliers avec ceux
qu' on pris en charge les marins
français dans les hangars transformés en
un vaste centre
[Musique]
d'hébergement mais l'élan de solidarité
n'a cessé de se développer et avec les
appareils qui se sont succédés sur le
terrain de Casablanca c'est un peu le
monde entier qui est venu à leur
[Musique]
secours quant à la ville interdite il
n'y restait plus sous les ordres du
prince moué Hassan que des équipes dont
la tâche était désormais de mettre tout
en vre pour couper le chemin à
[Musique]
l'épidémie sur les décombres qui
recouvrent plus de 6000 morts peut-être
allit s'abattre des tonnes
d'antiseptique on devait faire appel aux
avions pour P nuag de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
DDT et pour des jours peut-être des
semaines il n aura plus rien de vivant
dans Agadir en ruine en dehors de
quelques
bêtes quand le jour sélev sur la cité ce
qui avait été une des villes les plus
RANTES du Maroc grand sur une des plus
belles res du monde n'était plus que
ruine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici ce qui reste de l'hôtel Saada le
Palace le plus moderne de cette cité qui
attirait par la douceur de son climat
les touristes du monde
[Musique]
entier l'anéantissement est à peu près
total de la vieille ville de la ville
nouvelle résultat de tant d'effort qui
avait donné à Agadir son style moderne
il ne reste que des immeubles éventrés
et des tas de
[Musique]
gravas les 15 marin de la base
aéronavale française qui a été
miraculeusement épargné avait été mis
aussitôt à la disposition des autorités
locales avec l'armée royale marocaine
ils avaient pu dès les premières heures
organiser les secours bientôt rejoints
par les éléments des bases américaines
première manifestation de la solidarité
qui allait se généraliser sous les
décombres il restait l'espoir de dégager
des blessés faible espoir les sauvteurs
les trouveraient-ils vivants c'est la
question que chacun se posait mais pour
un rescapé que d'espoir
[Musique]
déçu cette ville de 40000 habitants a eu
le suprême malheur d'avoir été frappé
pendant son sommeil et les bilans les
plus pessimistes de la première heure
devaient être dépassés 1000 2000 bientôt
4000 victimes et dans la chaleur de
sourdes menac allait s'opposer aux
efforts et aux bonnes volontés avec le
manque d'eau l'apparition des rats et
les risques
[Musique]
d'épidémie pendant ce temps on donnait
sans désemparer les premiers soins aux
blessés et parmi eux des
enfants sur chacun de ces visages tout
le tragique destin d'Agadir
miraculeusement sauvé il ne savaiit pas
s'ils avaient encore un père et une
[Musique]
MA